At the time.
I was excited to get the call,
but everything in my body said say no.
Oh, really excited about it for sure.
So totally different reactions shall we?
One,
two, three. Great.
Okay.
Started using the mask as a symbol of
just like craziness of being free of uh,
becoming something else. I started
creating these large black light painting.
Somehow the neon cutters allow me to
express myself like in a metaphysical way.
It got well received. Then it started
kind of calling me black light.
Okay.
Huh. How are you feeling? Um,
honestly I'm a little nerve wracked.
This is just completely outside my comfort
zone, which is the reason I said yes.
But how would you describe
yourself as a painter?
I think I would call myself like
a contemporary wildlife painter.
I kind of take the animal out of its
environment and put it on a background
that's a little more abstract.
When I was younger,
that's all I used to do is I used
to draw animals and I was completely
fascinated by animals and I still
have like a deep love of, you know,
everything on four feet. If I were
to ask you what your expecting today?
Um,
I know we're going to paint something.
I know I'm going to meet another artist
and I have no idea who that person is or
what they do. I mean, they could
be a tattoo artist for all I know.
All right.
Hi.
How are you pushing her name?
Black light. Black light. Okay.
Wow. Nice to meet you too.
Now I'm very curious about what you do.
Oh yeah.
This is my cool city.
What I do is like I'll do regular colors
and then afterwards I'll add a neon
colors on top of it. It works with the
glasses too. There's glasses. Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
No Way.
Oh my God.
What about you? What kind
of artwork do you do? Um,
I am a contemporary wildlife painters.
Paint animals. Okay. That's cool.
It's still sick.
That's cool though because if you paint
animals that we could do something dope.
Yeah. Um, yeah. Okay.
Cause I have some ideas.
I'm thinking you could paint the animal
and I could paint the spirit of the
animal. I love that idea, but like
super psychedelic with it. Yeah.
And you could go like kind of like
blend and the animal. The animal. Yeah.
Okay.
What if we did
something like, like kind of ground
the piece by this guy over here?
Yeah. Okay. Like for example, like this
will be your bird right here. Right. Okay,
cool. Then I'm nervous about
creating more sips. Good.
Without my normal process,
there is a possibility that I will
totally eat Kale, but I'm here.
Hey, black light. Do you want
to look at something like that?
So it's eight by 11 I didn't really know
what to expect. I'll tell you the truth.
I was thinking,
okay,
is it going to work or their style is
going to measure and of course personality
wise, you know. However, I
was really optimistic. I mean,
it was good. All right, you like that?
All right,
so,
okay,
let's see. I need to like,
I need, it's good start.
I had a dream last night about raven.
I wanted to paint some recently,
you know,
he had some birds and some of the work
that he showed me and I just thought,
well, what if we worked on kind
of a raven portrait together?
I think part of how we wanted to
collaborate is to both retain our styles,
but somehow find a way to
have it integrate so that
it looked like a piece that
was collaborated but not super separate.
Once we got these ideas going, it was
just, um, play with just like water.
It was just streamlined. So I really
liked that process of being able to,
on the spot, create something and
her ideas were really open to mine.
I think he has a really good
vision and imagination, you know,
even though our work is totally different,
we have a similar sensibility.
I don't know, it's a little hard to put
into words. I think it's just more of a,
the vibe.
Okay.
I feel that we, uh, managed to, uh,
bridge two styles
together and make it work.
That's really rewarding in itself.
Yeah.
Keep on coming so long here.
Left.
You have black lake
king when you're right.
You have some of Hoover supernatural.
Super.
Okay.
Hi everybody. Hello? Hello. Yeah.
Well, I don't know about you,
but when I got the call,
actually the call,
the email and the Instagram
message from Mra at the time,
I was excited to get the call,
but everything in my body
said say no cause it,
it made me so nervous. You so you
were, you were looking forward to it.
You weren't nervous the night before.
I was more nervous about the project
itself, you know, like, yeah, like, uh,
the hardworking, but anyhow, I,
it was great working with you.
I had a lot of fun and I learned a lot.
So shall we go? Ready? Ready.
Hey.
So we both kind of tried to
focus on our strengths, you know,
so I did a more realistic version and he
did this amazing psychedelic spiritual
version. Yeah. We like the, uh,
the raven because he has like,
it's like metaphysical,
uh,
we thought about rebirth a lot and um,
it like dying and being reborn into
a spirit animal and then, you know,
and then we have fun in
their worlds. Yeah, yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thank you for watching another episode
of between worlds from Jubilee. I'm Mari.
Super glad to see you here at the end
of the video. If you made it here,
you have the best, and I love
you. Go ahead and comment below.
If you couldn't make a rap
about what jubilee means to you,
I'll send you a free tee shirt. Um,
but yeah, subscribe, watch more videos.
Love you guys.
Peace option.